good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Wednesday it is
hump day a great day here at the toast
honestly and it's even greater because
I'm joined by a highly requested co-host
this is your second time on the toast
it's gbt her real name is Robin I will
literally never call you whatever I mean
my best friend's Brian but he's the
Points Guy and I've never called him
Brian in my life it's tpj Robin girl
boss town the internet agent tick tocker
and most importantly pop culture Savage
Savage Savage it's Robin gbt hi everyone
I saw the comments um when I posted that
I was gonna be a co-host which is the
biggest honor because I'm an OG shows
her like seriously and by the way
whenever I meet people in public a lot
of them are like oh I found you from the
toast I love that they're the best but
I'm not BSC Ben software celebrities
you're just the other highly requested
one but gbt is here and I'm so excited
Ben soft for celebrity is such a
celebrity that he couldn't even make
time for me this week yeah that needs to
be March by the way a hundred percent
but Ben would be like I want it for his
his podcast he needs to make it yeah so
Robin's in town you're a New England
girly you're coming to New York what's
on the sketch so I am going to be at the
Summer I Turned Pretty Premiere tomorrow
and as like an almost 30 year old this
shouldn't be as exciting as it is but
I'm literally frothing at the mouth
um and then here for the toast and just
you know meetings make them busy
um but I would rather be like in my bed
with my dog but if I'm not in my bed
with my dog I'd be on the toast 100
relatable statement yes I will also be
at the samurai term pretty Premiere
morning like we're just gonna be two
grandmas like fawning over the teenager
and of course which is like wildly
inappropriate but that's just what I'm
here for that's your team Conrad right
okay I I knew that what are you doing
Conrad in the did you read the books yes
so in the books like I was 100 team
Conrad but the idea of her like ending
up with Jeremiah like wasn't the
craziest thing yeah and also like this
season is going to be rough for team
Conrad burley's
um I'm not gonna like spoil I think
they're going like exactly on the book
yes exactly but Conrad for life but in
the show I find Jeremiah is so unlikable
yeah he didn't have villain energy in
the books but in the show he's like
scheming and plotting it's giving like
all that like Nickelodeon
um I'm so pretty like when he's doing
the dance yeah like that's just he's
cringe he's cringe but like I know if
like like when like if I interview him
or serum tomorrow I'll be like hi like
oh my God like you know what I mean but
I mean yeah I'm not a Jeremiah girl I'm
not a Jeremiah girl like you yeah no I
love that you come in the toes because
you know you know all my references like
you know just as much about pop culture
as I do but what you really bring to the
table is your obsession with Tick Tock
and what's going on on Tick Tock right
now so I need to get your take there's I
found myself on like so many different
sides of tick tock first right now I'm
in the Xi'an influencer trip drama do
you know about that yes what are your
thoughts let me give like a little so
she and like did this influencer trip to
Singapore to kind of dispel all the
rumors well what do we know about Chien
like their sweatshops they have
underpaid their employees it's really
like um toxic work environments they
make like 10 cents a week and so they
did this influencer trip to kind of
dispel all the drama they like found
these random influencers who I
personally had not heard of at the time
now they're coming out is all over
especially that girl Danny
um but it was kind of like you know this
is what our factories are actually like
and we're going to take these
influencers here and you know show them
the factories and the assembly line and
people were not buying what she and was
selling they were like listen this is
obviously like a model home it's not a
real factory this is not where your
actual clothes are made because the
facility they showed us was very clean
beautiful everyone it looked like Kylie
Cosmetics like it looks like Google yeah
with like these AI robots yeah it was
not so what is your take on the
situation well I'm shocked the girl that
eats chicken sausage with cottage cheese
and mustard wasn't on the trip she's
gonna be on the next trip she's my next
thing I want to talk to you about yeah
um I think the intention is good but the
execution is bad because what I always
say when I'm working with Brands is like
this isn't the 2016-2018 influencer era
where they could literally like shove
product down our throat and we think
it's real we see through this like
internet clearly crisis PR so I think
the person who came up with it it's like
that's it's good intention but like this
is not Tartan Dubai no and it's not
fully transparent because that's not
where they manufacture all their
textiles it's not no so unless you're
going to be like fully transparent just
like let people keep talking rumors
about you but there's like there's
Brands like Ryanair which is like a
really like cheap airline in Europe and
they like poke fun at the fact that like
they're cheap and they like lose bags
but they get social engagement on that
like when you're in on the joke you must
respect it more so true so it's like
don't try to be something you're not
Shin so true but what do you think about
the influencers who went like they're in
a tough spot now they say they weren't
paid but then they say they were paid
it's not entirely clear like what the
arrangement was but they were like just
kind of these like spokespeople before
she in as an influence yourself but also
somebody who sees it from the brand side
what what do they do totally I mean I've
also been like persuaded to go on a trip
or do something with a brand because it
was presented one way and then it was
executed another so I don't Place
initial blame on influencers who went
because maybe they were told it was
something that it was completely not but
um I was the influencers I got put in
this position this is being posted
anywhere I would lean in yeah I would
lean it's good advice yeah I mean what
else are you gonna do no I know at this
point like it's it's like when like I
would like lean in and I would also get
Glam and get a stylist because there's
gonna be a Netflix documentary coming
out about it so be prepared she's so
right be prepared what do you think
would be called the Netflix documentary
about it
okay wait give me a second okay
she in she out yes
yeah okay now the other thing going on
on Tick Tock that has absolutely
occupied every corner of my mind is the
girly I don't even know her name but she
basically eats the most vile food and it
has gone so viral she's like a health
and wellness girl and I think I read on
her profile she's like lost like 70
pounds and this is right this is how she
did it she literally sits down for every
meal with a vat of mustard a vat of
cottage cheese and a plate of raw
vegetables and apple chicken sausage and
she dips every single one of the
vegetables and the sausage into mustard
or cottage cheese and people have become
obsessed it is so disgusting like I
cannot fathom that tasting even apple
chicken sausage Parts yep the palm of
Hearts is the hardest to watch
girlies out there the cottage cheese
this is my thing where the is
Janelle where the is Janelle they
need to do Niche conversations they need
to have a celebrity boxing match cottage
cheese versus Janelle Janelle was the OG
Health girly who would make these like
forlorn it was it was the same thing
like she would dip things in mustard too
yeah in her I think she's a nurse and
she would like go on break yes and make
these like really weird
um keto keto yes you know but she's um
she's actually out of the keto lifestyle
now I've heard it yeah yeah she actually
dm'd me for PR moves back in the day
that's funny yeah she's really nice I
mean I don't know anything about her but
she looks so such a sweet girly but I
think Heinz mustard should put on a
celebrity boxing match with Chanel in
mustard girly and that's why you're here
at gbt thank you now the other side of
tic tac that I've landed on that is so
Niche I'm sure you have no idea what I'm
talking about no I think I would is it
the bariatric Cruise
no okay let me tell you
so I was seeing this Berry I don't like
are they talking about bariatric surgery
yeah so there's like a community of
girlies who have gotten bariatric
surgery who are like living their best
lives and they've you know there's so
many communities I just had never heard
of this one and they put together a
cruise wait I'm gonna be stupid what is
bariatric weight loss okay okay so it's
like you know girls whose entire lives I
mean it's boys and girls but it's mostly
girls their whole lives have changed and
they found a community how to like
maintain the weight loss and you know
any issues they're all having and they
put together a cruise
like they all went on a cruise together
okay and I think it turned out to be
like fire Festival oh no but like
nobody's really speaking out everyone's
like going back and looking at these
tick tocks it's very small I mean I know
I'm like very Niche right now I just
want to show if you had any insight on
bariatric Cruz I don't but that would
also be another great opportunity for
Janelle and cottage cheese girly I'm
like how we don't even know her name I
don't know I feel so bad
um please Stitch this I feel like it's
Haley I think it's Danielle but
whatever
um I have not ended up on bariatric
Cruise Tick Tock place I would love to
see it so the crews went wrong like with
the cruises organized by the group or
did they just go on like a Royal
Caribbean cruise that I don't know okay
that I don't know but I don't know what
exactly went wrong but it's like
everybody was like hyping up going on
The Bachelor bariatric cruise and then
everyone went silent and they're like
what happened to the bariatric earlys
what was the pyramid scheme that sold
the leggings
um base new cruises as well so honestly
I haven't seen this but Royal Caribbean
works with influencers all the time they
need to put them out to sea yeah and
write all the wrongs and yeah right all
the wrongs and invite
Danielle cottage cheese palm of Hearts
potentially potentially Haley yeah um
okay so wait real quick the other side
of tick tock that I love that yeah
um
uh
uh like UK makeup obsessed girlies oh my
God the girlies in Ireland the girlies
in the UK the girlies who are just like
getting wasted every weekend and wearing
so much makeup I'm obsessed with
watching those girls get ready yeah like
they are the new Alex Earl I completely
agree okay cool and they deserve that
type of support and energy from us what
are you currently obsessed with on Tick
Tock right now
um see I'm so lame like I love like I
always end up on well obviously I'm on
this isn't lame Swift talk of course but
like the summer I turn pretty edits yeah
like I'm on like the edit talk you are
always sending me like this and it hurt
edits it's like Taylor Swift music set
to like different TV shows that we're
obsessed with yeah I'm on edit talk I'm
on UK talk I'm trying to think of the
last like weird Tick Tock do you have
stem on your Tick Tock I do and nobody
else nobody talks about it okay because
like when they were talking about
banning Tick Tock in America because
like in China they're using it to like
teach kids science and math and here
we're just learning how to eat cottage
cheese
but it only happened to a handful of
users where now on your free on your
Tick Tock homepage you can look at
people you're following the you know the
the for you page and then there's also a
tab for stem where it's like you're
getting science and math and education
like how grasshoppers read and reproduce
sometimes I find myself like spiraling
me too I don't hate it me too so but I
haven't met anyone who has it maybe
that's for a reason yeah maybe we're
dumb yeah maybe they were like girl go
on stem but also
it's like it's it's giving like
Scholastic book fairly it's kind of fun
to end like it's kind of fun fun
educational but still entertaining
content yeah like when all the submarine
stuff was happening I thought I was
accidentally on stem what are your
thoughts on the submersible so this is
the first of all
um not funny
um I think that
it's
this is gonna go like a little like dark
and like sad no but like when you like
losing somebody is so tragic and when
you hear about tragic things that are
happening in the news you don't think
about like the families at home that are
like mourning the loss of these things
and obviously this is like the craziest
content and like the most bizarre thing
so people are it's going to create
discards people are going to talk about
it but people like fully die no I know
so like there are so many memes about it
which is just like how our culture is
and me calling it a meme makes me seem
like such a millennial no but that's
what it was yeah like there's memes
about it which I like I get because it's
it is kind of turning into pop culture
yeah but I think it's I think it's sad
it's this it's literally this and it's
like making me like not being able to
fall asleep at night I know and when you
think about like what they went through
at that time exactly like before it
happened yeah and I think the YouTube
aspect of it how like Mr Beast was asked
to go on and a bunch of like Maritime
content creators had previously gone on
yes so that's like the craziest part
about all of it I agree and I was
wondering if they could go into the
iCloud of these people to get the
footage that was taken before something
happened because they had their cell
phones yeah and Logitech controllers
Logitech controllers yes well now like
everything that I'm like planning on
doing I'm like seeing Through The Eyes
of the submersible like literally
yesterday I got invited and it sounds
like a once in a lifetime trip yeah but
it also sounds like the submersible like
it's on the water it's a like a it's
like a luxury like yacht experience in
like Iceland and I'm just like it's
giving Titanic it's also giving
something like I can so not see you
doing that's literally what Jackie said
she was like but like it sounds amazing
like you in Iceland I know but like when
the am I ever gonna go to contact
content like I want to see the world
yeah no I yeah you think I should go I'm
really struggling please go you think
please go but it's on the water the
whole time yeah well you like Doc and
like explore will the bariatric Cruiser
always be on it I I'm not going if
they're not okay so like if that's the
case run with it but yeah if that's the
case she should have put them back on
the rack because she was unqualified to
own those shoes I will never stop
quoting I don't even watching if you
watch Celebrity Big Brother no but it
seems so so up my alley but I love
Tiffany
yeah I would take a bullet for her yes
multiple times over again and again they
need to do a re-watch podcast and that's
a statement alone and sentence that
never should be said because there's a
rewatch podcast for everything but New
York needs to do a re-watch podcast and
watch Flavor Flav Flavor Flav I love New
York I love New York New York gets a job
and Celebrity Big Brother she is really
like not given enough credit for being
such a pioneer of reality TV not at all
did you watch Flavor Flav like in the
day of course and Tila Tequila like me
too like it was the type of show that
like when you're like your parents came
home you have to switch you'd have to
click last on the Comcast remote why
were we watching that obsessed Danny
remember Danny of course remember
pumpkin of course obsessed if you were
on well that was like I was more of a
Rock of Love girly and you know when you
kind of get into Rock of Love But when
you come in they give you a nickname
okay what would be your nickname when
you come
that's a good one what would yours be
um gbt gbt gbt you're in my phone as
Robin gbt but like honestly every time I
go to find your number I can't find it
because I'm like who the is Robin
yeah no like every time I look in the
mirror I'm like who the is Robin
but there's a whole other conversation
you are one of the first people who
started calling me like gbt as if it's
like my name oh cool and now every all
of my like influencer friends in this
space like so fun to have a nickname I
love it I never had one I never had one
grown up I wanted one so bad in the
eighth grade I tried to get everyone to
start calling me juice box and it just
like didn't it didn't catch that is
poetic I know I'm gonna change your name
in my phone to Juicebox I thought it was
like such a good nickname juicy and like
JB juicy for short not one person call
me it so like now 20 years later was
there an origin story no I just was like
what's a cool nickname okay and at the
time like you know like a lot of rappers
were coming up and I just like Juice Box
sounded like a cool girl I like it it
was it had potential you should have
started it at Camp so true because Camp
is the origin of the nickname I should
have just like switched schools and when
people ask me my name just say exactly
yeah yeah okay today's episode is
brought to you by Sephora so everybody
knows Sephora is your go-to destination
for Glam for makeup for everything
Beauty but you know Jax and I are both
entering our clean girl era Jax has
really been influencing me and you know
she's pregnant so obviously she's being
really cautious about what she puts on
her skin and her body and Sephora is
still the go-to destination for anything
clean beauty related they have a whole
tab you can shop so many of my favorite
brands that I already used and already
loved are clean beauty that I already
shopped at Sephora like milk makeup
house Labs I love their blushes the milk
makeup Hydro grip but also I'm
discovering new brands like I love
Mirror Beauty in so many of their
products are so fabulous and they're a
clean Beauty brand
so Sephora is just like the go-to
destination for anything clean beauty
related and anything beauty related to
if you've been wanting to get into clean
Beauty find out if brands that you use
are clean or just find new fabulous
Brands to look like your most gorgeous
self head to sephora.com clean you can
learn all about their fabulous products
so many uh brands that I've recently
fallen in love with thanks to Sephora
like westmin Atelier I love their
bronzing sticks I didn't know about
before but until I shopped on
sephora.com clean I found all these
fabulous Brands all these fabulous
products and I mean like look at my face
could I be more gorgeous and could I be
cleaner no I couldn't be cleaner so if
you're heading to sephora.com clean
check out all their fabulous products
thank you Sephora for sponsoring today's
episode today's episode is also brought
to you by roback I think it's safe to
say everyone is talking about roback
whether it's their performance hoodies
their polos their q-zips we always make
sure to recommend rollback for the man
in your life if you want your man
looking good then get him to row back
but now we're even more excited to
recommend Roebuck for all the ladies
roback just relieved released active
skorts and dresses and we are obsessed
perfect for a day on the courts a walk
with your dog a nice jog on a summer day
I love wearing a skort because chub rub
is real it is chub rub season it's so
hot and having just that protection down
there while also wearing like a really
cute skort is one of my favorite summer
hacks the active dresses featured their
trademark GTG technology so you don't
have to take your dress all the way off
when you go to the bathroom their liner
doesn't ride up it has great stretch
hidden pockets for all of your
Essentials and the women's joggers and
Hoodie sets from roback are literally
the softest pieces of clothing that we
own if you want to be comfortable then
these joggers and hoodies are for you we
haven't taken them off since we received
them they're really that good so with
Summer quickly approaching make sure
you're checking out roback and while
you're at it we strongly recommend
treating yourself to some of their
ladies products the men's products are
fabulous but like I think it's more
important that we take care of ourselves
you know I'm burning yourselves so use
code toast on roback.com for a generous
20 off your first order of performance
squirts joggers and hoodies Rebecca
spell called rho
b-a-c-k.com and that's 20 off when you
use code toast roback.com highly
recommend the score perfect for summer
time I just love a score I can't speak
highly enough of the rollback one
um you're gonna join me for the Fast
Five we've got actually really good
stories today a little bit of tick tock
a little bit of reality TV I know we
have similar interests it was extremely
easy for me to find stories and so for
that thank you no problem here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
now the big TV news of the day I think a
lot of people saw this coming after Pat
Sajak's retirement Ryan Seacrest takes
over as host after Pat Sajak's
retirement he confirmed in an Instagram
post on Tuesday that he will take over
the Wheel of Fortune roll from the
longtime host Pat Sajak in June Pat
Sajak announced his plans to retire from
the hosting game after 41 seasons and
this is what Ryan said I'm truly humbled
to be stepping into the footsteps of the
legendary Pat Sajak I can say along with
the rest of America that it's been a
privilege and a pure joy to watch Pat
and Vanna on our television screens for
an unprecedented 40 years making us
smile every night and feel right at home
with them Pat I love the way you've
always celebrated the contestants and
made viewers at home feel at ease I look
forward to learning everything I can
from you during this transition well one
he did not write that a hundred percent
two
he like he's gonna host my next like OB
GYN appointment like why is he hosting
everything that's kind of been the
sentiment people are like all right duh
like we couldn't have gotten someone
else and I have to say like I actually
don't hate this no no no it's great
because he is host but you are a comic
and right and he will do this till he
retires this is the job you have for
Life yeah like what oh this is so like
uncultural to me who like used to host
the New Year's Eve
Dick Clark yeah like it's it's gonna be
like that like that's his Destiny
um but like never forget him and
Julianne Huff who could like that is
just like what resonates in my brain
when I see him who would want to that
was literally the most confusing the
most iconic and the best relationship
for both of them like for him he got to
be with a woman you know obviously much
more beautiful and for her she got this
springboard you know have you seen The
Tick Tock of her doing Footloose
rehearsal I haven't
it's hot like she's so talented no like
there's like a scene with her and the
main guy and footloose and they're like
grinding to like Country Girl Shake It
For Me Oh actually I have I have so um I
wonder if that was pre or post Secrest
um but I think it's great I mean I I
can't really see anybody else doing it
I'm not a Wheel of Fortune girly but
they should um start posting clips of it
on Tech talk and maybe get somebody some
younger audience yeah or get younger
people on the show on the show yeah
Okay it definitely has its demo I don't
know what does this mean for Vanna
she's so on it I know but like if
they're ushering in this new age with
like a younger host not that van is old
but you know what I mean like she's part
of the the the the patches Jack crew
maybe they revamped the whole show they
definitely need younger contestants
I you know Vanna White was like the
original like you know Instagram model
like we need an Instagram model yeah but
I think there would be an uproar if Anna
was pushed out it would be like there's
rats at the Mark there's my the Mark has
mice yeah the mark denies the Holocaust
um I think there would be more of an
uproar even though the the last host him
leaving is like and Ryan coming in I
think it's great like I think people
aren't gonna be like up in arms about it
but I think if Vanna left it would like
cause something but maybe this is an
opportunity for a new reality show of
somebody to replace Vanna White kind of
like the Glee project of course can you
believe how far the Glee project took so
many people also I'm on Glee project
Tick Tock yeah I mean Alex Newell just
won a Tony which is insane they got
their start
the Glee project which is kind of like
the Jimmy Awards
that by the way the Jimmy Awards that's
a very Niche reference that I just
discovered on Tick Tock last night you
didn't know about it Renee and the
Jennifer Lawrence is co-star in the new
movie I didn't know um it's a musical
theater yeah are you with like a big
musical theater girl I did I did
unfortunately I did do musical theater
growing up Robin do you sing
like Robin no sing no no but I did
Growing Up please sing for us just like
a little bit like 10 seconds no I
actually can't because like this is your
stage but like maybe you're just kissing
my ass so I don't know maybe if they
come on a third time I will oh okay
she's getting for an invite yes
um but yeah I did musical theater
growing up oh that's so interesting I
didn't know that about you I was a
musical girl musical theater girly and a
camp girly which is why I am now a gbt
girly which is why you are a toaster
which is why I am a toaster yes tell me
about camp like what camp did you go to
so I went to Camp Huckins in Freedom New
Hampshire
um it was all girls but we would go over
to like the camp Bell nap for like dance
social stuff with the boys and if okay
so my first like thing I ever had with a
boy was at Camp his name was Lucas bird
I'm pretty sure he lives in New York he
went to Yale and he was on the rowing
team and if he sees this and knows he's
gonna be like I don't know who this
woman is I've never seen this woman by
the way everyone's first boyfriend was
like some dork yours is a Yale rower and
his like SEC like third generation all
of his family went to Yale was like my
dad owns like um a Mexican restaurant
like I know I'll go to jail but um
at the Belknap dance if you were
speaking to A boy kissed a boy grinded
with a boy at the end of the night he
gives you his Belknap sunglasses so you
wear it to like breakfast the next day
to be like right I'm like kind of like
wearing a sweatshirt or something
exactly like I'm pinned and I can't and
I was leaving and he didn't give me the
Belknap sunglasses and I was like I'm
the Biggest Loser by the way he looked
like the guy from the Hannah Montana
movie which I probably shouldn't have
said his name because it's fine okay
um Lucas Till no Lucas bird and my name
would have been Robin no I'm talking
about from Hannah Montana yes the name
again
and a robin bird is like such a cute
name no but
um then like two days later I got an
envelope in the mail from camp and he
mailed me the sunglasses
um I know what toaster is probably
dating Lucas bird uh you know like he's
one thousand percent if Lucas bird is
worth his salt he's dating a girl who is
a toaster one thousand percent and I I
mean it's a toaster in his life maybe
Lucas has a sister yes so Camp was great
uh by the way I she went to an all-girls
Camp I too did the social we didn't have
the sunglass thing but it was like a
sweatshirt or whatever it was so fun and
they made you dress up funky or funny to
the dance so you couldn't be like trying
to show off for boys and stuff like that
because it's all about like girl females
oh no we all dressed like horse yeah but
like I was like oh I'm dressing funny
but like tied my shirt up you know the
boys like a cups out for the boys how
long did you go to camp for it was like
either two or four weeks and I switched
it wasn't like the long camps that I
know a lot of people do but I also
volunteer at a grief Camp called
experience camp that I know and I'm
going in like three weeks a lot of the
volunteers are here in New York it's a
free one week camp for kids who have
lost a parent sibling or loved one and
most of the counselors have lost a
parent sibling or loved one but you
don't need to go through loss to
volunteer um you don't have to kill your
parent to come together exactly exactly
um but
um yeah it being able to go back to Camp
is just like no hi that's why we did
Camp toast like I'm all aware I feel
like you were someone who like could
have been at Camp toast I had a wedding
I was gonna go though because like
that was me like I'm a toaster I'm a
camper it was so much fun yes and by the
way I'm like
I'm so connected to your family because
like I loved the show that your Camp was
on oh MTV's pet camp yes iconic and like
Diane Diane Sweet Home Alabama yeah and
so Ryan Seacrest is now hosting Wheel of
Fortune that was a journey and Diane is
gonna be the new Vanna White uh she
should yes
um okay next story Tick Tock drama that
I'm like kind of obsessed with so Sophia
Culpo's X Braxton Barrios and I keep
calling him Braxton Hicks like Braxton
Hicks contractions has addressed the
cheating allegations amid Alex Earl
romance so if you don't know what's
going on Olivia Culpo's sister was
dating this football player for two
years like a serious relationship I'm
pretty sure she was on the show I think
they live together I think that a house
together and it all seemed to be going
well until you know everyone on the
internet was like wait did they break up
and then there were rumors that he was
spotted out with Alex Earl and people
were just like very confused about the
timeline and so vehicle started being
really like vulnerable and honest on her
social media in the last couple of weeks
and months just being like this is like
the hardest thing I've ever gone through
I think she talked about how she's like
lost a lot of weight it was just like
true heartbreak yes and now over the
weekend pretty much confirmed Alex was
out in the Hamptons with her new man
Braxton Barrios Sophia kobo's
ex-boyfriend so people were like are
they aren't they and now it's like
confirmed they were like kissing they're
dating and Sevilla coppo took to
Tick-Tock to you know talk about address
to address she deleted the tick tocks
that she made but she sub talk it was
yeah there was a lot of subtext the
subtext was like the timelines like
maybe overlapped uh he's a narcissist
he's a cheater she was like liking
comments about him cheating yep so
Braxton yesterday blew this case wide
open and took to Instagram and addressed
everything okay that's the back story he
said I don't want to start anything I
don't want to fuel anything I genuinely
want all of this to be over and
everybody to move on and do whatever
makes them happy I was in a relationship
for two years it was a good relationship
it was a healthy one and towards the end
of it we had conversations along the
lines of why we guests weren't working
out so we split back in January that's
why basically like marking the timeline
as like him and Sophia breaking up in
January and I don't believe him and Alex
were spotted out until early February
which is quick but it's not an overlap
Sophia maintains that the timelines
overlap okay
Alex is silent yep Braxton was she
silent or was she silenced and Braxton
says it's clean it's it's kosher yeah
what does it mean okay here's the thing
like I
have met both of them and they're both
great girls
um I just
there is nothing worse than if you were
like sitting with your girlfriends and
you're like this is the girl that like
my ex is dating and everybody's like oh
my God no she looks like a human toe
like don't worry like if the photo is
Alex Earl like that hurts not only that
but like Alex rolls in a very rare
position in her internet Fame where she
is universally beloved there's not like
hate Pages for Alex Earl like every
influencer people just love her so she's
this darling girl who couldn't be nicer
in real life like the sweetest couldn't
be more beautiful has the exaggeration
of millions of people and
that's who your ex who you loved and
built a life with is with it's very
tough so incredibly tough like I
couldn't even take it when like my ex
started dating like a rat well your
words not mine I don't know her I don't
know her no I'm kidding um but the other
thing to bring to the table is think
about I mean your Situation's a little
different like when you're 22
I was like trying to hook up with this
like mailman that I met at a Mexican
restaurant in Nashua New Hampshire well
like drunk texting my ex like when
you're 22 things go awry and especially
in relationships but to make it public I
at the end of the day let's cut to the
chase I see where Sophia's coming from
from being upset I would be torn
and who knows what the real timeline is
but to get back at an X
the best way to get back in an ex is to
stay silent move on with your life
especially and make an unbothered Queen
and make them think we like what is she
up to I haven't seen her post it I
haven't seen her posting like she's not
upset like I guess this didn't mean a
lot to them and I'm not saying to be
toxic but like if I was Sophia PR moves
for Sophia I would literally never
address it continue living my life
continue building her brand or and doing
what she's doing and just completely
move on because to look
like you're upset which she so should be
she has the right to be upset but to
portray that is just like gonna make
people look at you like oh she's just
salty oh she's just a hater yeah like
whatever but Braxton I really wanted to
him address it I wanted him to address
it on Tick Tock with the blue eyes
filter that Alex always uses yeah
because like that would just have like a
hint of Alex in the frame yeah which
would just be everything
um
I don't think he needed to say something
I kind of think because some the other
arguments are being like oh he just
wants a spotlight he's so into himself
he's looking at himself in the mirror
and the reflection that you've seen like
that like yeah I mean there there's an
argument to be made that like Braxton
isn't the most famous football player
yeah but I don't think anybody had you
know followed his football career until
Sophia and now but I'm sure the toasters
did because the toasters follow football
or like footballers footballers who are
like dating girls right but before that
like he's not now he's not known for his
football no no no he's known for his
dating life so if he's gonna lean into
that you know what I mean I hate it yeah
no lean in but there's gonna be
discourse like if you're posting an
Instagram story like addressing like
internet beef and drama right like I
just wonder what the locker room looks
like for him yeah I mean this is like
it's so different and it's so crazy and
I support women in this situation not
all situations because some women are
the worst but I support the women here
and I do wish these two because I like
them both of course they should do like
get ready with me to go have dinner with
my ex's ex yeah like if these two could
meet up and like really just kind of
power to the I think and Jake's
there Jake chain literally like power I
think it would be very powerful yeah for
the young Community because now it's
just like so classic you know of course
and that's like I I could not agree more
like if they came together and were like
hey no not even a dress like but it's
gonna kind of be like hey we were kind
of being like crazy like whatever but
like they came together in the end and
did a get ready with me like imagine the
views and not that it's all about views
but it is but it is no and like first of
all I love that idea and I agree and I
think that like it's entirely possible
that like what Sophia's saying is the
truth and what Alex believes do you
think there was a hey girlie DM
exchanged no
no okay I don't think that these two
have ever communicated really yeah okay
that's just what I believe and I I'm but
I have no facts or like I don't know
anything that I'm not sharing like I'm
just like guessing yeah it's just like
kind of the the love triangle I didn't
see for for this year yeah like they
could like maybe tart
um sponsors just hang out I'm at I love
yeah I love a touring in the mix yeah
Marine in the mix a Target ready with
maze Alex and Sophia like and it's like
we're blending
I can't believe we're talking about Alex
and Sophia again it's giving call her
Daddy it's giving call her daddy I'm
like Alex and Sophia like I'm I'm having
drama I met Alex for the first time in
in can and how was amazed amazed yeah
she's shorter than I thought yeah how
tall are you I'm 5'3
how nice for you yeah I'm like four you
know I'm just length like it's like it's
giving like Pilates yeah Gwyneth Paltrow
exactly whether you have a puppy that's
a few weeks old or a senior dog who's
seen many years any dog person like Jax
and I know that the most valuable thing
in the world is spending time with your
pet and the farmer's dog can help keep
them healthy and can give you more
quality years with your stress bro I'm
gonna get emotional during sad the
farmer's dog makes and delivers fresh
healthy dog food it's recommended by
vets it's nutritionally balanced and
it's made from human grade ingredients
in safe clean kitchens it is the best
option for dogs at all stages of life
because it's not kibble it's not canned
goo sliminess it's just real food
traditional dry and wet dog food options
are very processed they can use much
lower quality ingredients than they
claim to and they're extremely difficult
to portion accurately the farmer's dog
isn't just a higher quality food they
also send the food pre-portioned
specifically for your dog based on your
dog's unique nutritional needs it makes
it easy to help maintain your dog's
ideal weight which is one of the biggest
indicators of a full healthy life a
fresh diet has also been found to have
all sorts of benefits Theo oh my God his
breath is so much better shiny coat
better skin better breath better
digestion smaller better poops so a
healthy diet isn't just important for
humans
Theo is a testament to that it doesn't
matter if your dog is young or old it's
always the right time to begin investing
in their health helping you live a more
healthy happy and full years together so
get 50 off your first box when you go to
the farmersdog.com toast there's never
been a better time it's never too late
to invest in healthy good fresh dog food
for the stress bro in your life so
that's the farmersdog.com toast for 50
off all right next up we're talking
about our Queen Kelly Clarkson and she's
addressing her rumored beef with fellow
American Idol winner Carrie Underwood
which I didn't never heard I never heard
but if I sat down and thought about it
I'd be like yeah why don't these two
like ever they don't talk they don't
collab they don't have any issue like
doing a song with
um Sanjaya
okay well first of all it's not that
random first of all they're country
girlies I feel like they will spend a
lot of time in Nashville Lambert and
Kelly do they ever love Adam too
he is the most underrated artist when
you did the muffin man on stage Do You
Know the Muffin Man yeah okay so Kelly
Clarkson is insisting that she does not
have beef with Carrie Underwood
obviously this happened on watch weapons
live and a viewer asked while calling
into the Tuesday episode
Kelly cut her off it was like I think I
know where you're going with this people
always pit us together and we don't even
know each other well enough to be pitted
together literally we've run into each
other a handful of times there's no beef
between us she doubled down that there's
nothing going on with her and Carrie
Underwood
um and then she let the viewer finish
her question but she literally cut off
the question mid-show I wouldn't I never
thought of it but like okay the answer
like I want to believe Kelly but the
answer seems kind of like I don't even
know her it's giving like you know
Mariah Carey as they say in the Bravo
Universe especially in the Watch What
Happens live like where there's smoke
there's fire
and that's always come true on Bravo
it's so true it's always but I'm a Kelly
girly and like I've been watching her
entire press tour and like she's
straight up and she name drops in like a
good way like honest just so honest so
true so I have
no reason to believe that this isn't
real but like at the same time it's like
we don't really know each other that
well that's kind of red flag that's kind
of like but you you do and you should
but Carrie Underwood I'm a fan and
anywhere as well she's a mystery yeah
like she's a private mystery like I have
no idea what she ate for breakfast or
like who she did like I know nothing
like she's not posting on Instagram
she's like a front-facing celebrity like
she does her brand deal she has like a
athleisure line she performs but we
don't know her person at all yeah but
like I feel like we used to and then it
just like stopped after like she had
that incident accident yeah
um which to each their own like she
deserves all the privacy in the world
she is a queen so I don't know but but
my question is what were the rumors I've
never heard of this me neither by the
way and so I never thought about it but
now I'm thinking about it yeah I guess
like when you when I think about like
the girls in country a lot of them are
like really like supportive of one
another country no I'm talking about
Carrie Underwood now yeah like when I
think about the the the country girlies
they all collab together they do songs I
love it it's so sweet they uplift each
other the big ones work with the littler
ones like yeah but I feel like Carrie
doesn't do that like I feel like the
only collab she's ever had
with another woman in country and maybe
I'm misspeaking because I don't know her
entire discography is her iconic song
with Miranda Lambert All Those Years Ago
something bad but like what else yeah
oh something bad one more time
and then they did it for NFL Sunday
night yeah which is the best but so like
she doesn't really like you know work
with women in the industry or anyone so
when somebody's extremely successful
like Carrie Underwood
this I don't want this word to be looked
at negatively a lot of what they do is
calculated they have a chance of giants
yeah it's strategic
um so it must be for a reason
um but yeah I'm not sure but like what
would their beef be over I guess just
like competitiveness you know like they
came up but that's the industry being
competitive not them I know but they
were launched on the scene at like the
similar time from the same platform they
were probably in like 15 years ago like
fighting for a lot of the same
opportunities yeah and songs yeah but I
mean Carrie could never play the role of
um from Justin to Kelly no it's a role
only Kelly could do yeah so like I can
get maybe that's where it stands that
movie is so unbelievably good it's so
good like do you guys remember season
one of American Idol like I remember our
teachers would write that like the phone
number on the board like everybody was
talking about it my eyes were like glued
brought the country together and like
that finale episode was like three hours
long and we would go back to Kelly and
Justin so how did you vote for Reuben or
clay reuben reuben won as he should yeah
in my humble opinion and I love how
they're besties now I know when they're
going on tour together we should go we
should go we should go I think they just
do like cover songs and which is
great I'm so down they're like picking
up on like the Jonas Brothers doing like
all of those albums and cover songs and
such Kelly um also want to watch weapons
live she you're right she's being like
so open she's talking like she's name
dropping everybody in the best way she's
giving the people what she wants she
understands her audience so she pled the
fifth on this one question that I
thought was really interesting and then
after she said she wouldn't answer she
like dropped a little hint the question
was like Kelly over the years has said I
actually think she said it on watch
weapons live many years ago that when
she got off of American Idol like it was
so hard to work with other celebrities
because the American Idol had this like
tacky Vibe but nobody wanted to work
with like the two I love the talent show
girl
um and so many celebrities were so mean
to her and Andy was like plead the
feather answer name a celebrity who was
like rude to you and condescending she
was like I can I can I can and Andy was
like okay and then she said but I will
will say one of the celebrities who was
mean to me ended up on a show like that
meaning a judge on American Idol a judge
on X Factor the voice the voice so it
could be JLo she was on American Idol it
could be who's currently on American
Idol uh Katy Perry I mean Nicki Minaj
and Mariah Carey were on American Idol
for a while that was chaos that was the
best season of my life Demi Lovato was
on X Factor Britney Spears was on X
Factor how awkward is that moment on X
Factor yes
Chloe's like so who is the best like who
is the best in Fifth Harmony Demi Lovato
gave like a critique of Fifth Harmony
and was like you know honestly only one
of you was like really performing and
you can hear it in the crowd and you can
hear it in your vocals and the rest of
you need to step up and they were like
okay and the club is like wait who and
they were like okay next judge and then
Chloe goes no Demi who are you talking
about who the fact that Khloe Kardashian
hosted a season of X Factor is not
nearly spoken about nearly as much as it
should and the fact that I used to
follow
a band for The X Factor follow I would
literally no no no no like go on the
tour bus oh oh oh no not me which is
like I would wait with baited breath it
was everything before they removed
released any actual original music after
X Factor they had this stint where like
once a week they would post a cover on
YouTube
the way no I wouldn't breathe until the
cover came Lego house Lego house
literally and it was really like the
Camilla show like it was the Camilla
show we would just wait for Camillus
yeah
you weren't there if you weren't there
you weren't there I feel so sorry and if
you haven't seen the Fifth Harmony it
was like judge's house judges house
their first performance ever as a band
they weren't even called Fifth Harmony
they were called lilas love you like a
sister and they sang impossible
[Music]
I was gonna say I was gonna say trivia
question who was the guest Simon
Cowell's house the guest judge was Marc
Anthony and when you watch when Camilla
starts singing Mark Anthony it's like I
just keep chills it's the best go watch
it on YouTube like whenever I'm like
drunk and like sitting around with my
friends and like watching our favorite
YouTube videos I'm like Lila's
impossible
second to that judges house is Carly
Rose son and Claire singing heart uh
brokenhearted to Will I Am and Britney
Spears and he goes she's a dragon she's
a dragon Harley by the way that whole
season of X Factor was life-changing it
was the best the fact that the guy who
won we never heard from again Tate
I he was like an older country singer
say something he won never heard from
him again the world did not do
Carly Roseanne and Claire we didn't do
enough for Carly where Santa Clara she's
on Tick Tock yes she is
but also you know Fletcher the singer
who sings like she was in the three girl
country group that like didn't last that
didn't last very long that season yeah
of all the singing shows we've had X
Factor was the best one and the fact
that it didn't like take off Remember
When Rachel got eliminated who's Rachel
it was first season of X Factor she was
like this little yes of course and she
fell to the ground and Simon hugged her
she was really young yes that was sweet
that was sweet I like loved those shows
it was they raised me it was everything
everything okay next story uh speaking
of watch weapons live Andy Cohen is like
found himself in like a little bit of
drama and I actually feel really bad for
him I was gonna say so he is thanking
his fans for support after this nipple
video from New York City Pride goes
viral so Andy Cohen has expressed his
gratitude to the fans who supported him
after a video of him playing with a
man's nipple during New York City Pride
went viral so followers took to Twitter
to lambast the sleuth-like videographer
who's secretly recorded the Bravo bigwig
during an intimate time so if you don't
know what I'm talking about and I didn't
know either but everyone was like Andy's
video Andy's video I was like what and I
searched up on Twitter I felt like I'm
part of the problem I am the problem but
this is my job I need to know yeah and
basically and he was at like a pride
event and it wasn't a pride event it was
it's Pride so you know all the gays are
out living their best lives the best and
he's clearly at like a bar it's very
it's getting like underground it's
giving no phones yeah and he's like you
know I don't know if he's seeing this
person but he obviously had he was
having a night with this man the man is
sitting on his lap the man is not
wearing a shirt and Andy is like kissing
his neck and rubbing his nipple which we
love which yeah and
somebody recorded it and the watching
the video the video was so invasive like
it's it's such a private moment it's so
it's such a tacky really disgusting
thing to do and then of course because
it's Andy it went viral and people were
like making fun of him and you know
calling him gross names but his fans
have really kind of backed him up and
been like which I love I love this never
should have been recorded you're you
know a grown ass man in a private ins
bar like you should be able to do
whatever you want live your best life
you know Love Is Love yeah I feel so bad
like I think it's so like it's probably
embarrassing and it's so invasive and
it's a video that never should have been
recorded and especially during Pride
where like you're supposed to just like
be free be free and celebrate like being
able to love who you love and what some
people have gone through to be able to
be themselves outside in public it's
like so
like the fact that people are
disrespecting that I think is disgusting
I hope the person who posted it like I
hope like but literally I wish only the
worst for them but also I think it
speaks to Andy's fan base and like his
relationship with his fans because I'm
glad we're getting to a place where when
things like that come out it's not like
oh my God like this is great but it's
like hey this is kind of like
uncomfortable for me to watch because
like why is this out there and like this
shouldn't be out there no it's so true
it feels like sometimes internet culture
and just like fan culture in general has
like no moral compass no people just do
and say whatever to like get attention
or get close to uh you know get an
interaction on on social media they just
say these absurd things so it's
sometimes disheartening to talk about
stuff like this because like people
don't realize that like celebrities are
people with feelings wait I'm not I
didn't did he address it on watch what
happened five no but on Twitter he like
a bunch of his fans were like listen
don't be ashamed we don't care we love
you and he was like thank you so much
the person who recorded this is like a
trash human being so he's he's not he is
addressing it but not maybe he's gonna
do it on radio Andy this morning but and
we should never make light of the
situation because it's wrong but imagine
if he had the guy who he was with as a
bartender
this is why you are the internet agent
that is an amazing idea yeah but only if
he was comfortable like you know what I
mean but like because that's the other
thing yes Andy's a public person and
this is stuff he just you know you have
to deal with when this is your life but
like the other guy is not and his face
is not blurred out in the video he's
just a regular guy and this culture
where we record people without their
consent I'm not talking about
celebrities I'm talking about when I'm
on Tick Tock I'm always seeing people
recording like random and yeah maybe the
people you know are doing weird things
in a restaurant but like this culture
where we're so comfortable recording
people we don't know especially people
who are like maybe having dinner with
their kids like minors it's so
weird to me I don't like it and I I do
not do that I do not subscribe to that
and I do not like content like that and
this is coming from a fan like I'm a fan
at heart like I love Pop Culture
celebrities and like if when I see a
celebrity I'm like oh my God dying but
then I think about it I'm like what is
recording them like what a second what
is what is that gonna do you're gonna
have it in your phone just to look at
like it makes no sense no it's like
posting on it and so many of it goes
viral and it's like the person just
didn't consent to your Tick Tock
yeah it really it rubs me the wrong way
I don't like it yeah no I agree I'm like
so hesitant to get to the fitness final
story because I know it's a topic you're
just as passionate about as me
um and it's not good news in the Zolciak
Beerman households
so before I have The Robe before I tell
you no before I tell you the story you
do of course collections of course
before I tell you the story what was
your initial reaction when you heard
that these two are getting I was
devastated I was absolutely devastated
because this is gonna kind of sound off
topic but it's not like I watch Teen Mom
and like you watch these girls like give
birth to their kids and like I'm so
invested in the Teen Mom stories because
you've literally watched the life be
born and like live life like yeah we
watched them meet yeah and she was like
that's the finest ass I've ever seen I
have to tell you it's the finest ass
I've ever seen in the ballroom dancing
competition in like Buckhead Atlanta and
it was literally love at first sight
like you could tell the chemistry on
screen like it was palpable and listen
like I don't agree to like face tuning
your kids like there's a lot that Kim
does that I'm like ah but like that's
why she's so iconic she doesn't
give a but I but what I always
would say was like but I think she's a
really good mom and I think that like
her relationship with Croy is like so
genuine and nice and they went through
so much they went through so much her
family and his family I was gonna say
like you know when her parents were like
spilling stuff to the media and just
like her time on Real Housewives like he
was a pillar no he was like it was like
him and Chef Tracy like
that were like grounded them no if you
watched Don't Be Tardy the dog bite the
dog bite that but that footage from The
Ring camera like chilling I can't like
they've gone through so much they've
gone through so much and like if you
watch the show like yeah she's like you
know the wigs and it's like all it's
funny and whatever but if you watched
their show and they were on TV for like
seven or eight seasons like they were
such a family unit and genuine and they
had such love in their house and yeah
they did things you know unorthodox and
who cares they had so much love in their
house and like you couldn't watch a show
and not really take away that like this
was like a beautiful family and that's
the thing it's like when she was on
housewives it was like oh like she's
crazy whatever I was still always a fan
because I was an OG tree fan but we'll
get into that later but like when she
was on Don't Be Tardy it really was like
lifting up this layer where you're like
they really are just like a family that
like deeply loves each other like she
would cry when the kids were like three
eating lunch thinking about them going
to college no I know because she's like
I just like I love them so much which I
thought was so sweet and Kroy was the
best yes and how we adopted Ariana and
Brielle like everything he was just like
so so to hear that they were getting
divorce was honestly like not to be
dramatic it was really difficult for me
genuinely hard and things have gotten so
messy it's so bad and they've gotten
worse because Kim Zolciak is claiming
that Kroy Biermann threatened to have
her friend arrested for kidnapping son
so Kim's also I got to call 9-1-1
yesterday so it's like a confusing story
she called the cops on her estranged
husband Croy after he allegedly accused
her friend of kidnapping their son okay
so an audio from the 911 call that of
course was obtained by TMZ which is also
crazy I know the whole fact that you can
like hear 911 calls it's like so weird
it's like a podcast literally so Kim can
be heard telling the dispatcher that she
allowed her girlfriend to pick up KJ for
a play date at the rodeo
Kim then claimed that the former NFL
player began making threats about filing
kidnapping charges after learning about
the arrangement this is what she said on
the 911 call Corey has harassed not only
the mother her friend but my son is
shaking and hysterically crying and now
I'm just gonna leave and go pick him up
to prevent the situation I don't know
what else to do at this point she also
accused her ex of stealing her bag with
divorce papers amid their messy split
according to the call this is just so
petty I hate to call 9-1-1 for this
situation so basically
Kim's friend picked up KJ and was at her
house
Croy found out that Kim wasn't the one
who picked up KJ but it was Kim's friend
and was alleging that it was a
kidnapping and we don't know who this
friend is we don't know if it's a
reliable person I don't know in this
situation like who is the crazy one
because they're both saying she's saying
that he is a drug problem he's saying
that she has a gambling problem like
they're throwing the most like vile
accusations at each other I don't know
who the the wronged party is here well
you know the only person who could fix
this was Grandma Rose and she's not here
anymore you're right
they all went downhill like and I'm
shocked that Grandma Rose didn't see
this coming I know because she was like
a teacup like psychic girl like yeah I
don't know I think that
divorce when it gets messy is like the
most unfortunate thing because if you
think about it
it once started off as love
so it's like you're hurt more when like
somebody you love stabs you in the back
then like when somebody you hate does
obviously and when you have a family and
build a family and have children with
somebody it's like divorce is like you
can hit somebody where it hurts yeah you
know everything about them and I think
that I don't know who's in the wrong
because I don't like like I said I don't
know the details like I don't want to
like get into that because I'm literally
not in their family and not a divorce
attorney but like I think that they are
both
they know how much they love the kids
and like they're like using that against
each other which is just like so sad
um
the gambling thing is it crazy though
have you watched that Tick Tock where
the girl goes through her bank
statements yes but the gambling thing is
crazy but it's like actually not because
if you watch the show she's always at
the casino there's like a record of her
just like her favorite thing to do is to
go to the casino and my favorite thing
is to go to a casino so like I've seen
someone saying I have an addiction but
you know there is a long history of that
but it's like the crypto yeah like some
girl on Tick Tock literally which is
and the fact that like your all of your
finances become public when you like
like she was going this Grand Tech talk
went through her entire bank statement
and like summarized it I was like if
somebody did that to me
literally and stop ordering like old
episodes of flavor love on Amazon Prime
like but I don't know I it makes me it's
it's really really sad and I think that
I think it's unfor I hope not I think
it's only gonna get worse yeah
um but she is on the new season of
Housewives I'm obsessed I also was
really happy to see that Ariana and
Brielle wished a Happy Father's Day to
Croy I didn't see that yeah I like that
brought me like peace like this whole
situation is really with me
I know like
Brielle and Ariana too like that's a
whole other sub I mean I feel like so
much has happened in the Biermann Clan I
totally forgot that Ariana had a DUI
like last year yeah but then it came out
that like she didn't
that's what they said yeah well I'm kind
of I'm such a Beerman girly like I
follow all of them on like I'm obsessed
with this family and Don't Be Tardy was
taken away from us and it shouldn't have
been the last season like where they
were in an artist that wasn't the best
but it was actually like amazing all
good reality shows end in an RV like
Johnny K plus eight like one of their
last seasons Kate took an RV and like
they had she had like an explosive blow
up
um on the RV I love Johnny
um and then this the RV seasons are
rough simple life they had an RV season
did you ever see the movie with Robin
Williams are they
with JoJo yeah what are you talking
about that's probably one of my favorite
stories of all time I just said this
once a week added to the list add it to
the list yeah but no it's and like
recipes Robin Williams like that is his
finest work yes and Jojo Jojo uh I think
this was the mom from Curb Your
Enthusiasm it's this it's a brother I
think like a nobody
I think not but whatever it's so good
it's so good but that was JoJo when she
was an actress yep she loved her actor
era I have a trivial question for you
okay what was the name of the guy that
they wanted to date in Aquamarine oh I
have no idea Raymond and they're
like Raymundo oh I really remember about
aquamarine is like I would have given up
both of my legs for the starfish
earrings and like I would get fish food
from Ben and Jerry's like at the grocery
store because she ate it in the bathroom
a hundred percent like that's like how
sick sick and disgusting I am I relate
to you and I think the toasters would
relate to that too yes I love you I love
you too you crushed the Fast Five thank
you thank you for being as passionate
about these moronic stories as I am and
I also just wanted to say
Jackie I have an idea for the camper and
the counselor oh my God PR moves for the
camper the counselor and I miss you and
I hope everything is well
um I think that they should do a redhead
episode where they bring in kids and
read the camper and the counselor and
have her like interview the kids in like
book club format
um on their thoughts on the camper and
the counselor and take video footage of
it to put on Tech talk because there's
this Tick Tock called recess therapy
where like this guy like interviews
little kids in Central Park yes
um they should do that with the camper
and the counselor I knew you would come
prepared and you did not let us down
today Robin Del Monte gbt thank you if
you're not following gbt on all
platforms we wish you well yeah but if
you want to at girl boss Town Instagram
and I was gonna for some reason to say
fine Instagram and Tick Tock yeah
premium content premium PR moves premium
pop culture content and it's been an
absolute blast I'm so glad you came back
and we're gonna have to have you come
back again on Jackie's actual maternity
leave time in my life love you fighting
dragons with you literally guys thank
you so much for listening to the toast
we are back in studio tomorrow with
Jackson Claude a regular episode thank
you so much for listening to the test
Monday Morning Show we deliver the past
five stories in YouTube every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available podcast
and we're podcasting we found Spotify
and wickedly talented we are have an
amazing hump day dear toasters will be
tomorrow with Jackie love you bye thanks